our entrepreneurs born or made the
classic question one that came in from
one of my newsletter readers miss Gunn
now hope I pronounced that properly
wanted to know our entrepreneur is born
or me one of my advice that there's a
certain personality that you need to
have as an entrepreneur and what is it
so there's a great question and I do
believe that there are some inborn
traits that you need to have to have
success as an entrepreneur but they're
not the ones that most people think of
and they're not the ones that I thought
of when I was first getting started
I believed early on that to have
successes on entrepreneur you needed to
be a rockstar you know you needed to be
an outgoing person you need to have the
type of a personality you couldn't be
shy because these are the ones that we
hear about all the time and that was
limiting for me because I thought well
I'm not that guy and you guys may not
see that but I'm I'm usually a pretty
shy guy I'm not the one who's handing
out my business cards and promoting
myself I'm not the type a personality
and then by researching famous
entrepreneurs I found that that's not
true at all there are a lot of
entrepreneurs who have started up who've
had massive success who are introverts
who are not the ones who are out
pitching itself and pulling themselves
all the time those are just the ones we
don't hear about as much because the
other guy is the type A's are the ones
making all the noise so those are the
guys we hear from so you know I have a
personality test as a hundred questions
you go through to determine if you're
meant to be an entrepreneur or not but
the main thing I would think about is
you have to have the ability to get
started you know you have to have a
drive to want to do something you have
to be motivated you have to take action
these are the common traits amongst
successful entrepreneurs they had a
vision for something and they wanted to
see a change in the world around them
and they had the drive to go and do
something if you don't have Drive you
won't have success if you're not willing
to go out and make a change you're not
going to have success as an entrepreneur
and so there are some things that are
inborn that you have
have that that can fuel you to be become
a highly successful entrepreneur but
they're not the ones that most people
think of that are limiting personal
beliefs and I believe everybody can't be
motivated to do those things you know if
you if you want to have dry for
something you just have to be motivated
by the right things and a lot of people
have no Drive and have no motivation but
it can be switched around so don't be
held back by your limiting personal
beliefs don't be don't don't limit
yourself thinking well I'm not born to
be an entrepreneur so we'll have success
most of the things that you think are
holding you back that you think you need
to be successful entrepreneur are not
really real factors in your success it's
a good luck and believe those are
watching you like the video please give
it a thumbs up below it makes you want
to do more for you and I love to hear
get to think leave a comment below or
entrepreneurs born or made let me know
what you think you have a question leave
it below - I'll make a video response
thank you and I'll see you soon